monsieur brunel bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
selon andré chassaigne chef de file pcf
ce texte n'est pas urgent au regard de
l'afflux blissement des pouvoirs
législatives selon vous le gouvernement
tentent ils de profiter de la situation
épidémique pour faire passer en force ce
texte on va accuser le gouvernement de
toute façon depuis le début de cette
crise sanitaire qui est inédite à la
fois humaines sociales et économiques
depuis le début donc c'est tout et pas
tout passe par ordonnance de toute façon
le parlement il est toujours averti en
dernier si on prend notamment le
déconfinement du 11 mai la déclaration
du premier ministre le lundi dans
l'hémicycle on l'a su nous parler mais
dionne le samedi donc voilà c'est
inadmissible de faire passer donc ça
d'après midi ou de mal et ses pulls et
le projet de loi qui est proposé par la
députée public en marche alors on ne
rentre choses à faire qu'il ya quelque
chose de dramatique que les députés ne
sont même plus réunies en nous et 150
députés à des situations exceptionnelles
on prend des mesures exceptionnelles
et là le gouvernement le fait en son nom
mais sans les députés le boycott des
communistes selon vous sera-t-il suivi
par d'autres groupes parlementaires je
l'espère parce que de toute façon c'est
rien à voir aujourd'hui et tout ce qui
se passe dans le monde et dans ce pays
donc il faut absolument que le parlement
reprenne ses droits
il ya des salles qui peuvent contenir au
moins beaucoup plus de députés
aujourd'hui avec des distances qui est
qu'ils sont notamment convenus et donc
un dessin disponibles on veut revenir
dans des salles de 1000 à 1500 personnes
les 577 députés qui doivent jouer leur
rôle
la démocratie est aussi les porte parole
des citoyens de leurs circonscriptions
voilà le gouvernement actuel mende abuse
de sa position et abuse des ordonnances
et essaye de faire passer comme si rien
n'était au niveau des dés de la
situation d'aujourd'hui
concrètement qu'est ce que votre projet
qu'est ce que vous reprochez f1 projet
de loi via on reproche rien on reproche
qu actuellement d'abord on va en
discuter
ne sois pas on dit c'est pas à rougir de
loi qui doit arriver aujourd'hui à autre
chose à faire on a une situation où on
vend plus de 10% de demandeurs d'emploi
ou les commerces sont à l'agonie où
l'indus qui va reprendre en mettons
peut-être pas toutes les conditions
sécurité sanitaire pour permettre aux
salariés de travailler
c'est ça qu'il faut qu'on discute il
faudra discuter des gens ils auront
discounter le déconfinement ça veut dire
quoi
quand on dit on va viser avec le comique
19 et ça veut dire quoi
si on dit que le jour d'après ne sera
pas celui le jour d'avant
mais il ya le pendant il ya ce qui
existe encore aujourd'hui on va faire il
n'y a rien qui est fait à ce niveau là
tout est fait comme si ben comme si on
était comme avant pas voilà ça continue
comme avant et à la limite le gobie 19
c'est comme si que ça n'existait pas
c'est ça que mon prochain gouvernement
il faut que le parlement se réunisse il
faut que le parlement puisse être
écoutés et entendus pour réunir
justement le parlement qu'est ce que
vous proposez pour la fonction règle
pour en fonctionnement régulier de
l'assemblée nationale evans il faut
changer leur faut plus qu'on se réunisse
dans l'hémicycle qu'il faut respecter
les règles de sécurité à respecter avec
de distance et donc il faut qu'on trouve
des salles qui sont beaucoup plus
importantes qui nous permette que chaque
député
à ces quatre mètres carrés pour pouvoir
disputer puisse intervenir
il ya bien des 5 existe par ce pays pour
qu'on puisse se ruine il faut que je
parle on retrouve sa vocation sa
fonction première
c'est à dire de disputer des lois de
faire des propositions de loi et en même
temps dans cette situation qui pratique
et inédit je le rappelle il faut
absolument que chaque député chaque
groupe puisse voir si ce plan est aussi
proposée il faut que vous arrête de dire
moi je sais tout je pense tous le disent
qu'il faut faire non c'est pas forcément
ce que les gens disent ou et il n'est
pas forcément la confiance qui est aussi
au niveau des citoyens que 8 65% des
gens ne font plus confiance à ce
gouvernement et maïs est temps qu'il
s'en remette en question
traitant qui se lisent en a pas
forcément raison pour vous et écoutez
aussi les députés hausse est occulté les
citoyens ont peut-être écouté organisme
syndical
voilà ce qu'on dit il faut revenir à une
situation inédite avec des mesures
exceptionnelles
merci beaucoup alain bruneel d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes député communiste du nord